[Music]
highest Michelle from lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD and human
calculator I recently did a video on
hand sanitizers and I've got a lot of
questions and even though I tried to
answer a lot of questions I think a lot
of those answers got lost in the many
comments so I thought I put everything
into a video I've put the link to the
first video in the description it covers
what you need for a hand sanitizer to be
effective the sorts of ingredients that
won't work examples of bad hand
sanitizer recipes and why they're bad
and some extra tips on using hand
sanitizers correctly so your hands will
actually be sanitized and you're not
just wasting what is now liquid gold
watch that video first the link is below
if you want more information on kovin 19
in general please refer to the World
Health Organization's website and other
reputable organizations like the CDC as
usually if you like this sort of content
talking about the science behind beauty
products press the like you can
subscribe to my channel and click the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos more about issues with DIY hand
sanitizers first off I wanted to
elaborate a bit on the warnings about
making your own hand sanitizer I think a
lot of people interpreted the fact that
I was saying that a recipe could
theoretically work was the same as me
recommending that you make a particular
recipe I don't recommend making your own
hand sanitizer over using a commercially
prepared one or just washing your hands
all of this is for educational and
harm-reduction purposes if you're going
to make hand sanitizer despite all these
warnings I wanted to be theoretically
capable of doing what it's meant to do
so again only a commercially prepared
hand sanitizer is to some degree
guaranteed to be effective and safe make
DIY recipes at your own risk some of the
issues that people generally don't take
into account when making their own hand
sanitizers are the fact that alcohol
evaporates and even if you're quite
experienced at formulating you can still
make measurement errors in a properly
formulated product they will re measure
the alcohol concentration at the end to
make sure whatever you put in is what
you actually get out pharmaceutical and
cosmetic grade ingredients are generally
safe to repeatedly put on your hands
food grade is also generally safe
anything else is a bit of a crapshoot
but the only recipes that I endorse
the ones that the World Health
Organization has put out and even then
only if it's made by someone who knows
what they're doing can I add this
particular ingredient to my hand
sanitizer when you're making a recipe
that has other ingredients apart from
what the World Health Organization has
recommended you are running into a bunch
of risks these ingredients are water
alcohol glycerin or glycerol and
hydrogen peroxide a lot of people have
asked me if they can add oils to their
hand sanitizers so if you're using
something oil-based essential oils or
vitamin E oil these oils do not mix with
water in a properly formulated product
you have to add soluble Isis to make
sure the oil actually disperses and
doesn't just sit on top and so as
possible you'll squirt out a handful
that is mostly oil and only a tiny bit
of alcohol and then even though overall
the whole thing has a safe amount of
alcohol a particular amount that you
dispense may not I've also been asked
about adding moisturizing ingredients to
protect your hands from drying out the
World Health Organization recipes use
glycerin as the moisturizer if you use
other moisturizing ingredients you can
run into problems so for example aloe
vera gel is biological matter that can
go off inside your hand sanitiser aloe
vera gel products do often contain
preservatives but once it's mixed into a
hand sanitizer it might not be preserved
enough even with a really high alcohol
content there's also been a lot of
people saying that aloe vera gel balled
up inside their recipe and they don't
know what to do even if you don't see a
large amount balled up in your recipe
you can have small amounts balled up
that you don't quite notice and so if
you get a lump of aloe vera gel again
you're going to be dispensing something
that is less than the required amount of
alcohol onto your hand even if the
overall product has enough alcohol if
you've added some random moisturizer
into your hand sanitizer you might have
any combination of these problems and I
feel like this goes without saying but
don't try to sell your DIY recipe the
regulations around the world generally
treat hand sanitizer as a therapeutic
good and so it's regulated differently
from normal cosmetics where is the link
to the alcohol calculator it's in the
description of that video and of this
video if you expand the description
scroll down a bit
it is
how do you use the alcohol calculator so
once you've clicked the link a new tab
or window will open you might need to
sign into your Google account then click
make a copy you'll have a spreadsheet
look down the bottom for the one called
alcohol calculator click the down arrow
next to the name and click duplicate
this makes a copy so you don't mess up
the original now you can enter your
recipe for example this recipe uses 96%
ethanol it uses 1/3 of the cup of
ethanol you'll need to enter fractions
as decimals the conversions are down
here so 1/3 is not 0.33 change the unit
to cups by pressing the down arrow here
and select the right one then you can
enter the other ingredients the same way
turn any rows you're not using 2-0 then
the percentage of alcohol will show up
here
will ingredients other than alcohol
sanitize my hands I said this in the
last video and it is still true now no
other ingredient apart from a high
alcohol concentration is recommended for
hand sanitizers is alcohol-based hand
sanitizer pedal or surf in water so the
main advantages of hand sanitizer are
it's more portable so you can use it on
the go and it tends to be less drying on
skin than washing your hands apart from
that washing your hands with certain
water is better apart from just killing
the viruses it also washes them away
what is the difference between ethyl
alcohol and isopropyl alcohol they are
different ingredients ethanol or ethyl
alcohol has two carbons isopropanol or
isopropyl alcohol has three they are
very similar but they don't have exactly
the same properties ethanol is gentle on
skins and isopropanol in lots of studies
it has been found to be less irritating
isopropyl alcohol is bigger and so you
generally need a slightly higher amount
to have the same effect so it's
recommended that how much ethanol you
put in is somewhere above 60 to 70
percent isopropyl alcohol is above 70
percent what do you do if your source of
apple has just high enough concentration
to work I recommend using it as the
sanitizer and then moisturizing your
hands afterwards just remember to make
sure that you let the sanitizers stay in
contact with your skin for 20 seconds
before you moisturize what do you do if
your alcohol is lower than 60%
concentration there isn't really much
you can do you can't mix it with
anything to make it a higher
concentration theoretically you could
distill it but I don't recommend doing
this if you don't have the necessary
skills and equipment to do it properly
it is flammable and setting yourself on
fire is much worse than not having hand
sanitizer just wash your hands can you
use methylated spirits methylated
spirits is generally ethanol combined
with something else depending on the
brand it can contain methanol and if it
does I do not recommend using that on
your skin if you don't know what the
other ingredients are I recommend asking
the manufacturer and the warnings about
different grades of products cosmetics I
am acidic or grape all of those still
apply will detergents work as well as
soap for disinfecting your hands in some
places there is a hand soap shortage so
luckily pretty much any cleaning product
that foams up is likely to work
the same way so body wash dishwashing
detergent shampoo all of these
surfactant containing products should
work exactly the same way in killing
viruses as I said in the last video the
corona virus has a thin lipid envelope
around it that soap or detergent can
dissolve
this'n activates the virus plus the soap
or detergent can help germs get washed
away
how can you disinfect surfaces so health
authorities like the World Health
Organization would recommend using
bleach one recipe is using four
teaspoons of bleach in one liter of
water when you're using bleach don't mix
it with other household cleaners because
it can often produce toxic gases this
includes bleach and vinegar bleach and
ammonia and bleach with alcohol you can
also use detergent just like with
washing your hands and of course high
alcohol concentrations work as well I
wouldn't recommend using bleach or
detergent as a hand sanitizer because
these are very harsh on your hands
vinegar and essential oils are not
considered effective for disinfecting
your hands all surfaces what are some
ways to boost your immune system to
fight off the virus eat healthily
exercise and get enough sleep there are
social media rumors that things like
zinc vitamin C colloidal silver vitamin
D echinacea and elderberry might work
there aren't any approved vaccines or
drugs or anything else that are
considered effective for treating or
preventing the virus and supplements
aren't always harmless as you might have
seen someone has died for trying to take
chloroquine if you're in a part of the
world where you're taking vitamin D
because there's not enough sunlight then
keep taking unlike you normally would
this isn't a good time to do a detox
juice cleanse or a fast you don't want
to limit the nutrients your body has if
it has to fight off a virus it's also
not a good idea to suddenly ramp up how
much you're exercising if you didn't
exercise before start gently so that
your body doesn't have something extra
to deal with so I hope this video was
useful if you liked to it please leave
me a comment give me a thumbs up and you
can subscribe to my channel you can also
follow me on Instagram and check out my
blog for more beauty science please stay
safe do your part to flatten the curve
try not to share misinformation and I
will see you next time
you
you